welcome to rough and cloudy special
announcement coming in hot added to
rough and rowdy 19 December 9th I put
together one hell of a crew for calabas
fight companion show who will be
watching it live with the boys
it's a human sex doll
this is Robert Rowdy welcome fellas this
is the craziest environment
what else you want tune in
[Applause]
we flew him all the way from New Jersey
to Calabasas California he is a living
legend the former 155 world champion of
the UFC on today's food truck it's
Frankie Edgar my first guess ever
and I'm feeding them barbecue
this is tank
let's go
I
need everything I get super thick boy
used to have a model [ __ ] now I got a
thick one yeah I do last night went late
yeah we had a sick one not very drunk
yeah and I like the legend himself Mr
Frankie Edgar what's going on brother no
man out here in Calabasas with you yeah
the weather's better than jersey better
in Jersey for here it's awful yeah for
Jersey it's a summer day no jacket on
them good I know you look good brother
look good for a retired man we're tired
now you look happy I am happy man I
can't complain yeah Life's Been Good
Legend status yeah gonna get that first
ballot Hall of Famer we'll see I mean
that's not up to me but yeah oh no I
guarantee it yeah yeah guarantee it yeah
you Tom Brady about to bet on people
getting the Hall of Fame yes you and Tom
Brady I like that now I'm not been on
James Krause
no uh yeah man I mean think about it
when you first started what stand there
you're starting 2005 what 17 years ago
17 years ago 17 years bro
17 years in the UFC well 16 years 16
yards so you got five what five fights
outside the UFC yeah but by the time you
get so you know yeah 15 years in the UFC
just think you know you'd be doing it
that long I mean honestly I remember
being in college uh my my coach was 30
years old he just got done he's like 32
just got done competing I remember
saying I'd love to be able to competing
on 30. yeah and here I am 41 so you know
so it was cool it was a great career man
you know I'm happy oh great I mean
that's honest I mean if someone would uh
read through the names that you've
beaten when you were you know just on
UFC like get the hell out of here yeah
it's the who's who I mean for sure the
best of the best bro yeah I always
wanted to look I always want you know
when I got into this I wanted to say
when I'm done with my fight career I
look back and I just fought everybody
and it was good that's what you know
everybody across three-way classes yeah
I mean and literally the the
former Champs current Champs Euro champ
it's just like I mean straight up Hall
of Famer career I mean the thing about
you beat Charles Oliveira I bet you
didn't think he was gonna become
Champions especially if I'm back then
yeah I mean I know he was you know he
was young as hell too so uh he had a lot
of potential I remember Chow saying
you're going to appreciate this win a
lot more in the future the jail said
that yeah God bless him because I was
never that no we're going around on
Charles Oliveira but I was never that
high on them I knew he had talent but
early in his career you could you saw
some quit in him yeah so when he started
you know ripping off some wins I was
like yeah but when the going gets tough
then even after he proved himself I was
like yeah but that's in there and then
it's not and the Chandler fight he could
have easily taking it he could have
because he was getting whooped at first
yeah dude he's a straight Savage so
um I mean retired UFC Legend and it's
kind of like now for you it's like to me
it's like now granted you're the outlier
you know it's been basically 15 years in
the UFC we which is an eternity but
still in 15 years of you know you look
it's just a chapter of the book
that's just the chapter of the answers
book absolutely so it's like now what
like now to me like your life is
starting if that makes sense yeah
because you had such a regiment like a
strict schedule you know all right I
fought I'll probably fight three times a
year maybe twice if I'm champ like you
have an idea how your Year's gonna pan
out right now it's like during this yeah
it's late it's exciting you know uh new
goals new things to chase you know and a
lot of time to do it so yeah I'm excited
to to see what's next I still have some
things I want to figure out you know I
don't have I'm not really set on what
it's going to be next but I have a lot a
lot of irons in the fire I guess you
said you've always been one of those
guys like since I've known you for a hot
second you've always had like a lot of
irons in a fight like obviously you were
taking care of business inside the
Octagon but you've always kind of
hustled on the side and doing your thing
like your business minded guy so you
Gotta Be You got to be you know you can
I always knew you know this was gonna
end eventually yeah I always try to see
what's next and yeah it's exciting that
now I have all that Focus right I never
really moved on too much like I always
had irons in the fire but I would want
to focus on myself like you were always
especially yeah you were always two feet
in but you were like when there was time
you you did have other kind of things
going on but it didn't take away your
folks right if that makes sense yeah I
know exactly yeah exactly so now I can
put 100 into what's next now yeah and I
think that makes it easier for a guy
like I mean doing 15 years it's like the
scary thing is when guys are forced to
stop and they have to stop and then
there's there's like they're like I have
no idea what I'm like I think everyone
deals with it like obviously
professional athletes are notoriously
known and really even the military you
know they served their four years they
have a special set of skills they're on
a strict regiment and then after four
years you know if they do decide to stop
doing military it's like we're good yeah
like literally the government the
America's like we're good yeah thank you
and they're like all right whoa what's
next I have this special set of skills
man and I'm not fitting into this nine
to five world like what am I supposed to
do so I think no matter you know
everyone suffers a little bit from that
kind of even college kids when you get
done you have a degree right and you
think it's going to turn out to this big
thing and really doesn't work like that
so again you're in college four years
military four years UFC average career
used to be a year and a half I think
it's a little longer now
um but you know you're so focused on
that you have especially the skills and
then you get done it's like what the
what's next it's so scary yeah it's so
scary it's scary and exciting you know I
mean a type of person I am I know uh I'm
not gonna just rest on my Laurels you
know what I mean I'm gonna go
attack something so you're the least
person I'm worried about we have a ton
of guys on the show and some with you
know we got cut in the mic so what do
you what are you thinking yeah should I
start doing stand up or I'm like I don't
know
yeah you'll see gym coach you know it's
like right right holding me it's a DLC
gym making seven dollars an hour it's
like it's [ __ ] tough it is tough but
for you I've never been worried dude
never yeah I'm uh like I said I'm
excited for what's next and uh yeah you
know I'm [ __ ] podcasting like you now
I did a little bit of stand up not quite
as good as you guys oh man it was fun I
mean dude it was good yeah yeah it was
it was a good time I had a blast doing
it I act in a movie this year oh dude
did you like that it was it was close
you know small budget film still but in
fact it's different right man you know I
had some good actors that were on set
with me really yeah isn't it amazing to
see like a real like when you see real
actors you get such an appreciation it
would yeah I jumped in and dude I've
never done it I mean I did kickboxer
movie I played Joe Rogan oh play myself
you know yeah you know how to do that
right that's not really action right
yeah but uh for this I mean yeah I'm
jumping in some scenes and it felt
comfortable because these guys were all
about it it wasn't like awkward you know
because they were all you weren't like
embarrassed yeah oh my God yeah this is
what you're supposed to do so it was fun
acting's work is completely what you
know we're used to especially with the
UFC where you're like in charge you take
control and you can kind of delegate
your day and it's like to me I've done a
few acting Goods is like the hurry up
and wait yeah which I was like let's go
yeah it's like one scene for that entire
day yeah oh it's wild and then I do
every camera angle and every game
we just blew up a car there's things
here here they're like yeah we gotta
clean all that up go to your trailer
like that's gonna take like four hours
dumbass
I'll just go back and then the scene
where I have no speaking lines I sit in
the back I'll wait four hours and do
that right right but then when you re
when you see like the actual actors like
I was I did a movie with Shia LaBeouf I
was on selling for two weeks now one of
the worst movies you've ever seen but
still just to see the talent of Shia
LaBeouf I was blown away yeah Blown Away
it would be like seeing you for the
first time not gone or like Jon Jones or
you know if you see Lebron in person
yeah like I was like Jaw open like
watching him act I was like this is
mind-blown how talented he is dude yeah
nuts he's a crazy artist right a little
bit oh bro the the stories I have for
you when we sit down maybe when I get
some food I feel like something I nuts
nuts no I think he's chilled out as a
kid now but I Knox dude and Brian
Ortega's on set with me yeah yeah he was
like down to fight both of us yeah do
you realize what's happening here this
isn't Transformers
he was a really cool guy
um no he was actually really cool I
actually yeah I have so much respect
when he's so talented do you do you want
to get into more acting you think I
would do it you know I don't think I'd
want it to be on the main thing but if
like you know something comes up here
and there I would jump on it yeah it's a
weird route right yeah
Hollywood style like if I you know stay
in Jersey and do it I'm down yeah if
like Marvel came to you to play like
Ant-Man or something yeah I'm not saying
too I'm not dogging your sides I'm
saying but if like Ant-Man you could
just fly here and be like Ant-Man that
would be pretty dope yeah but and you do
the podcast and uh what's it called the
champion of trench yeah Champion the
[ __ ] and you've been doing that how
long almost three years now three years
yeah yeah and you like it it's fun man
it's definitely fun I I Roger Matthew is
my co-host he's a good friend of mine he
lives in my town I do it in my basement
you know we kick it we have some good
guests on if not it's just me and him uh
and you guys would know him from uh
Jersey Shore he was jwow's boyfriend on
the show eventually they got married and
then they have two kiddos the young kids
yeah and he was on the shot like the
high yeah I mean that show was nothing
it was it was bananas man yeah I live
right over the bridge from where that
that uh that was filmed that's right it
was nuts in the summer when they're
around let's take a little break from me
chatting Frankie Edgar's ear off on this
episode of food truck Diaries because
I'll tell you right now I'm always
concerned about this online world we are
living in and people can steal your
identity and anything you do people are
ordering so much stuff gifts for the
holidays you're banking your bills
everything is done online you're putting
all this private information on there
and there are people out there that will
get that information you need to be
protected and you gotta use the
protection from my friends at Allstate
identity protection the best identity to
protection from a brand you can trust
you've heard of Allstate come on so much
of life life is logging into our digital
lives that's why Allstate developed an
identity protection product that
protects your Digital Life just like
they protect your physical life you have
insurance for your regular life so why
won't you do it for your Digital Life
think how much time you spend on a
computer on your phone and with all
state identity protection they'll
reimburse you up to a million bucks for
out-of-pocket expenses lost wages legal
fees they'll also cover money stolen
from your bank accounts 401ks hsas and
tax returns at Allstate they have been
protecting the things people love for
over 90 freaking years all right
think the identity protection your bank
provides is enough do you think again
the reality is that most financial
institutions Act only after fraud occurs
rather than preventing it why even let
it get started stop it from the very
start all right having comprehensive
monitoring and coverage from AIP will
help stop identity thieves in their
tracks before any major damage is done
what I love about Allstate identity
protection is it covers the whole Squad
my whole family my girl my in-law my my
brother everybody's protected it gives
me a peace of mind because we live in
this digital world there's all sorts of
information out there right so when you
think identity protection think all
state identity protection to find out if
your employer offers All-State identity
protection head to aip.com
if not get a 30-day free trial at
aip.com one last time that's aip.com
this episode of food truck Diaries Frank
Yeager is brought to you by better help
unfortunately life doesn't come with a
user manual listen so when things aren't
working out for you it's normal to feel
stuck and you don't know who to reach
out to navigating any life's challenges
can make you feel unsure whether it's a
career change a new relationship maybe
you're becoming new parent it's a lot to
figure out on your own should talk to a
real professional licensed therapist who
is a professional all right and uh my
friends at uh better help therapists are
trained to help you figure out the cause
of challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills so you're not
so stressed out better help has
connected over three million people with
licensed therapists it's convenient it's
online all right and as the world's
largest therapy service better help has
matched three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable all right just fill out
a brief questionnaire to match with a
therapist if things aren't clicking you
can easily just switch therapists no
harm done it's too easy it can be
simpler right no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
that's betterhelp.com
that's better
h-e-l-p.com job now let's get back to
the program and do talk about full
circle you retire and I don't know if
you remember this you were my first
technically the first ever food truck
guest when I flew up right yeah yeah and
we had that pizza oh yeah absolutely
pizza was great yeah tomato pie tomato
pie yeah man it was good oh yeah and
they said it was something the Jersey
water
that's what they said for the dough I
feel like everyone says that like the
New York New York City yeah yeah I feel
like your water's awful yeah yeah
I think oh that was a hot section that
was the that was like the seed that was
over five years ago oh yeah yeah yeah
six yeah but that was that was where it
got me the idea because I had so much
fun doing that we're just shooting the
[ __ ] and eating pizza I said we had to
do something like that but I can't go to
restaurants all the time I was like I'm
in L.A they have great food trucks
that's great so I pitched that money of
money here we are Man full circle dude
it is that's [ __ ] great Isn't that
cool oh yeah yeah Jersey was dope when
uh Jersey Shore like obviously exploded
literally one of the biggest TV shows of
all time especially reality tv as a I
mean you're the I think you're the mayor
of New Jersey I mean you're the face of
New Jersey did it did you kind of give
you how'd you feel about Jersey Shore I
feel like it gave you guys like a little
bit of a black guy right I mean it's
like Jeffrey Dahmer and Milwaukee yeah
yeah it did a little bit but I mean
everyone's like oh people really like
that I'm like yeah people really like it
I just thought they were like characters
no I mean listen they were eccentric of
like the height the height of it but
there's definitely some I know some
people like that really in Jersey
especially the club heads you know
[ __ ] Meatheads you know Meatheads
Molly yeah
yeah jewels and [ __ ] it looked fun
though yeah it was good times good times
the seaside yeah but you never went that
route no no no no no no no no yeah too
much yeah I mean I don't dress like that
yeah yeah that this that show I just
felt like kind of gave Jersey maybe a
little bit black guy but but it brought
a lot you know I have a lot of friends
and family that own businesses over the
bridge and it brought a bunch of
business to that I didn't think about
like like the tourism I bet yeah because
they put you guys on the map it did I'll
be honest like I'm familiar familiar
with like New York Boston outside that
man I mean I fought in Jersey that's why
if I broke up that was dicey that was
like my experience with jerseys
in New York Newark that's where that's
where it is New York yeah but then I'm
like an hour south of that yeah by the
beach there yeah a lot different yeah
New York they were literally like you
know what is it New York Newark Newark
yeah when I was walking down the street
like did you you'll see a rehears like
I'm just going to get a soda maybe not
yeah and I think it's that bad he's like
yeah whatever I'm walking down there it
was even someone from Jersey just
someone was like [ __ ] you okay some he
was American and I was fighting a
Croatian she was [ __ ] orange at me
dude get out for me
like I told you like no that guy's not
like some gang banging that's something
weird
anti-american-american and that was
weird dude
um yeah man uh yeah Jersey is a special
place yeah no it's cool even when I was
a kid uh they used to have the MTV beach
house in Seaside a punch even before and
before the show so like if we go over
the bridge check out the you know during
spring break and stuff it was always
like the the damage but I feel like
Jersey's getting a good name now because
most the like really success successful
people I know who work in New York all
live in Jersey they have to the Jets the
Giants yeah most people with Showtime
they're all in like Jersey absolutely
all the like the entertainers the rap
artists around Jersey yeah uh Joey Diaz
is in Jersey he is just moved there yep
yep I need to connect with him on a pie
I do yeah I tried getting him on ours
really he's tough to get to get out of
the house I agree he's supposed to be on
fight Pain uh on Friday and he was like
something came up he's like I can't
[ __ ] do it okay don't talk to me
why my [ __ ] sucker I'm six miles away on
route nine I'm like you're in Lakewood
you're getting behind the truck I'm like
all right we're here and then that never
shows yeah you know when I was doing uh
my promotes for my special in New York
he called he called me it was like he's
like he full name was Brendan chop
you're in New York you're not gonna stop
by and see me I'm like y'all come by do
you guys all right let's let's plan on
doing a pod tomorrow we'll do it
tomorrow at two o'clock I'm like all
right
noon I texted me Joey uh what do you
want to do man I'm trying to figure out
the schedule nothing one o'clock calm
hey Uncle Joe here man let me know what
you're gonna do nothing three days
you're still here no dude I left Joey
you know that's just that's Joey I'll
connect you and jump yeah yeah
absolutely I just contacted him he's
such a good dude he reaches at him he
loves fighting he does man he's the best
actually I got to see him there there's
a comedy club in uh by me uh Uncle
Vinnie's in point oh okay so I got to
see him perform which is [ __ ] Savage
right so good brought the Brock the
house dude and you could tell like the
first like it was like 45 minute set
like the first 30 minutes was like
something he had paired the next 15 he
was off the top and it was probably the
best [ __ ] out when he's just rolling
like yeah I mean literally shake the
walls like toughest follow of all time
there's only one Uncle Joe yeah it's a
nightmare yeah yeah like it's a
nightmare fighting you know on the Octon
and the guy before you some badass but
following Joey might be way worse yeah
it's like oh this is I mean all the day
he's funny all the time not funny all
the time non-stop yeah and then when
when he does your part to take those uh
those death stars yeah how many
milligrams are those whatever kills a
rhinoceros and he just pops like five of
them where most people they eat one
they're like comatose yeah I took one
and I'll never do it again yeah and
they'll just kind of boom boom they're a
pretty high tolerance I gotta hit him up
oh really oh dude tell him to bring him
when he does your pod it's gonna be so
fun melted on the couch oh do you see
himself on yeah he just goes dude yeah
he's the best the absolute best uh back
to the fight game so for UFC think about
when he started uh till now the game's
changed a little bit The Game's changed
a little bit it was when you were the
world champion at 55 is a huge freaking
deal
I and I don't mean to be you know I'm
the I love the UFC at UFC alumni bleed
UFC I really only cover UFC and someone
Championship but really I'm Mr UFC yeah
I love the UFC but I feel like the game
has changed a little bit just it's not
as
it's still star driven you have your
stars but there weren't as many stars
especially when you were doing it so I
feel like guys like you BJ Penn like
Chuck Liddell even Jon Jones Chael Sony
I'm still like I don't know to me almost
met more if that makes sense and and I
look at like you're resumeing the guy
especially the guys you were fighting
back then it's like there's no easy
fights in UFC especially now there's
guys who aren't even ranked who could
give the champ a real you know frit
absolutely back then to me I don't know
it may be because I don't know how I put
this maybe because they put on so many
fights now that's when it was like so
special back in the day like when you
were fighting it was like must see TV
and for us especially everyone on staff
and you it's like it's still must see TV
but I feel like for the population the
Casual it's like there's there's another
there's one every week yeah it's like
it's like you know WWE they just keep
going every week
you're only as good your own your last
fight yeah and UFC and even more so now
because literally you could have a great
performance on Saturday next Saturday
someone has a great people forget it
forget about yourself yeah you know so I
just felt like like when you were coming
up and like when you were like the champ
and doing your thing it was just like it
was just a special time man yeah a
different time it was fun um it was cool
to kind of I mean I started with Spike
then we went to Fox yeah ESPN so it's
kind of cool to come come up
who went versus when it was on versus it
was on Spike yeah yeah they went to Fox
and then ESP you know ESPN it's a big
boy yeah it's just like so mean I guess
I guess I it was maybe more Niche back
then but it was Niche and there was less
Stars so those stars were like there's
their star was so bright and then now
it's more mainstream so there's just a
lot more to kind of pick and choose from
I guess and that's not necessarily A Bad
Thing it means the sports growing which
is great I mean when you were doing it
it almost is don't take strong away it
almost meant more when you were doing it
I don't know you know I don't that makes
sense I think there's so there's so many
fighters now that there's someone like
for like back then there was only so
many so you had a group of fans for one
guy yeah now there's fans for everybody
there's so many different types of
Fighters so many people that are into
this you know yeah and it's like
when you were fighting you know the guys
were tough like especially those you
know those top like eight guys are all
superstars badasses you like it was
tough to decide who's gonna win like you
had these wars like I said now the
number 50 guys can give any top 10 guy
have run for his money yeah and you've
never heard them yeah some dude from
Dagestan South Africa South Korea keep
up it's hard to keep up with who's who
now 90 yeah yeah I'm just like same
let's give him random nicknames too like
who the hell is he talking about like
you don't know pachai no
you don't know padside well uh last time
you're on food truck
um we ate the pizza in Jersey which was
fantastic now I'm gonna feed you some
barbecue out of a truck let's do it from
but the the only difference is the LA
food trucks they're good in New York
certain like Austin has good ones
Nashville has good ones LA's the the
best capital for the food truck so you
know Mark Mark kind of ruined my food
truck stuff I mean I hear I'm good but
Mark's always like in New York don't eat
that the street meat I'm like why yeah
he's right he's like where do these guys
go to the bathroom where they wash their
hands oh my damn these are all fair
points all right these are fair points
and I would say you're overthinking yeah
yeah but he's also right right
especially New York's like yeah you
think that's chicken or is it the Rats
of the sky
you know so uh this should be real meat
if it's not you get sick
shot a fight coming up
let me feed you and continue this stuff
[Music]
that's what I got in here
[Music]
what's up brother
uh just like some barbecue man is there
is there a menu or
can I guess sandwiches that we have
fries
or sandwiches or chicken pulled pork and
brisket sandwiches okay and there are
loaded fries are with cheese the choice
of meat chicken brisket or pulled pork
with jalapenos oh gotcha they're all
loaded they're bombed those are my best
gotcha what what sandwich do you
recommend
my pulled pork and my brisket are like
they're both like
one-on-one they're both nice one-on-one
yeah yeah I think yeah we'll both do
brisket perfect and then do you want the
loaded fries you want to see your pants
later or [ __ ] it yeah he's going loaded
fry they'll do the regular fries I'll
probably try some of his yeah okay what
kind of meat would you like on your
fries uh I'll do the pulled pork I guess
pulled pork yeah and then two briskets
and a pulled pork yes sir coming up on
the triple double gentlemen thanks sir
triple double double
[Music]
let's take a little break from chatting
with the answer all the way from New
Jersey Frankie Edgar one of the best
ever do it and we are enjoying this food
I haven't touched mine I don't know when
the stats can be placed but I probably
haven't touched mine
um listen man I'm here to talk to you
guys about my friends at Rogue if you're
a regular viewer of any one of my
million shows I work too much you
already know that I love Rogue nicotine
it's one of the only sponsors that I've
ever had that I reached out to them your
boy got super thirsty in the DMS and I
reached out to Rogue all right I use
their pouch every day
every single day I use them on podcasts
at the gym riding my bike when I'm on
stage
um everywhere everywhere I use Rogue
anytime you guys have seen me even in
pictures people like you have a dip in
your mouth I'm like no throw nicotine
baby I use it everywhere my favorite
flavor is the Apple I have it right here
and then followed by the freaking lemon
the lemon drop I love both of them I
switch them out throughout the day all
right but they have all sorts of great
flavors they got Berry Wintergreen
peppermint uh like I told you honey
lemon the flavor of Rogue destroys
anything out there that's how I got with
them I tried a bunch of other brands and
nothing compares to Rogue they're so
tasty beyond the pouch Rogue also makes
other great nicotine products like gum
tablets lodgingers wherever you want to
get your nicotine they got you covered
um I'm a pouch guy I only mess with
pouches right
so I take it anywhere I want like
flights at the airport no issues comedy
clubs restaurants all good no
restrictions Rogue is my go-to source
for nicotine when I'm riding performing
I absolutely love it I reach out to them
like I told you guys to be on my shows
because I believe in the product so much
they are hands down the best nicotine on
the planet all right if you want to try
pouches like me or gums tablets go to
roguenixteen.com use the code rogue20
for 20 off your order again that's Rogue
20 for 20 off your order of the best of
the best nicotine
on the planet we're talking about Rogue
nicotine baby underage sale is
prohibited all right warning this
product contains
nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical
Dateline for more information visit
Rogue nicotine.com last break kids and
then we're almost on the home stretch
hopefully you're enjoying this episode
of food truck Dodge with Frankie Edgar
but I gotta let you guys know when
you're watching this show right now I'm
doing this ad right now I'm on Kratom
that's right but not just any Kratom the
best on the planet the only brand that I
trust I'm talking about happy hippo
happy hippo Kratom is the best hands
down and they're the only creating place
I trust to put that delicious stuff in
my body to fire up this brain I need all
the help I can get you guys know this I
mess up words all the time okay some say
CT I beg to differ I think I was born
like this big deal Kratom helps me step
up my game so if you want to step up
your game and get focused and feel good
and get that brain firing in all
cylinders use the best cradle on the
planet happy hippo it's the best focused
product you can use and it's all natural
I use the shots of the concentrated
Cherry shots they're in a pink can with
a thick hip on it boom I do that before
any shows and your boys
geared up that's right and if you want
to try Kratom and a company can trust
visit happyhippo.com use promo code sick
boy for 20 for Life use that code as
many times you want share it with your
friends your aunt your gay Uncle your
brother your sister it doesn't matter
the whole fan can get in on this that's
20 off for life when you use promo code
thick boy at happyhippo.com now let's
get back to the program yeah it looks
nice
smells good
dude yesterday
um you know I had three shows and I
picked up my new dog and I did I
realized when I got home at 11 o'clock
at night I didn't eat all day all day
all day you do that I do that sometimes
never on purpose yeah never I'm you know
I'm sick
it was like I got home I was like I'm
dizzy
and I it finally hit me I was like I've
been going so hard in the pain I forgot
to eat yeah yeah I made coffee on a
weekend I'll drink coffee in the morning
I won't be like three o'clock I'm around
like oh [ __ ] I didn't eat yet yeah yeah
can you just when you're like going
non-stop the problem it must have been
hard for you not at 55 because you know
you could eat a Philly cheesesteak and
do your thing and still make way but at
45 you have to kind of watch your diet
right I did
I did not as bad like first time I'm
going down 45 I never got all super
strict then I realized like I was only
walking around 55. yeah I'm good 35
though was I had to be Shrek oh that's
right 35 dude that was that was was that
a nightmare no honestly man I do
everything right like I start eight
weeks professional I'm 100 disciplined
you know we get a fight if I cut eight
pounds how did you feel at 35. I felt
good I felt good never felt like uh
I mean I felt skinny definitely skinny
you know you feel weaker no I felt
pretty solid felt good yeah I did isn't
it strange to think about like if you
know if you're born 10 years later like
I wonder if you would have fought at 55.
right yeah can you look at the 55s now
like oh dude it's my size huge Patty
pimlet yeah we got food truck 220 pounds
oh yeah that's crazy I mean it's just
they're getting bigger faster strong so
it's like I wonder if you like I want
yeah
10 years forward right into the future
you're born a different time like you
would have probably start off at 45 but
you know you know probably been champ at
35 45 like double double champ I think
God yeah they're not interested yeah
absolutely
I like the way it went though you know
I'll say I fought it all three different
weight classes you know I agree it's
cool and then to be the world champion
55 as a smaller dude I also think that's
why he kind of blew up and everyone's
like rooting for you not to say you were
Rudy but you're like the smaller like
runt of the division and doing work yeah
yeah you know definitely I I
that to me that's mostly you know watch
we watched first UFC was always Gracie
fighting monsters you know it's kind of
what I was doing a little bit you know
you're fighting nonsense you know what I
mean like great man and that's like
that's like the true martial artist's
technique it's always technique strength
is for the week yeah Enzo Gracie always
say strength for the week yeah you know
technique is is King yeah until you make
strength and technique well yeah yeah of
course now and now it's time but now I'm
with you that's and that's really helped
what you're just too start from like for
the smaller guy who's in a song like
that technique yeah you're like that
you're like the poster boy of that yeah
like those great Vineyard fights where
you know you can knock down come back
first of all reason was offsides yeah
and him played one play he won't play
right one the whole story yeah yeah
let's do a bet on it's like I think I'll
piss you off if you're Joe Montana like
they made a move about Rudy and here's
Joe Montana
won a national championship you're one
of the best quarterbacks to ever do it
and dude you can't even get a lifetime
special they can't even do one of those
lame Hallmark movies on Joe Montana and
Rudy's like the top sports move of all
time the guy was offsides it's insane
you know you know the other thing is is
going so hard and Rudy the whole thing
is is hey to upon this game went to
prison for it but no uh afterwards bad
guy but then also before that he was in
the military so the military paid for
his school to go to Notre Dame so in the
movie you know where it's like he's
trying to figure it out and like his his
family he's like he's whatever they're
working class yeah yeah we're glad
military [ __ ] yeah that's why Joe
Montana hates us wait did he win a Ponzi
scheme Rudy yeah years later so he went
on a whole uh speaking tour like going
around the world like a motivational
talk off one play talk about turning
[ __ ]
[ __ ] hey made it happen chicken poop in
the chicken soup dude I mean one play
and he was like cool say less I'm gonna
create an entire business around this
and they got in trouble with the Ponzi
scheme uh
that didn't you know you think about Joe
Montana he's like I'm one of the best to
ever do it national champion Notre Dame
NFL MVP super MVP I sell Skechers you
know what I'm saying like that's like he
literally hates Rudy if you ever if you
if if I Joe Montana I'm here it'd be an
hour special on how much we hate Rudy
yeah we both hate Rudy oh that's funny
dude he was offsides to start with so it
shouldn't even be got started and then
Joe Montana's like well it's not like he
won the game for us we're by 30 points
they put them in yeah and then he's like
they put him on his shoulders to make
fun of them
when you hear them talking like chilling
towns I hate her but also I get the
results
weird rant on Joe Montana back to you
and Rudy um
and the games changed too in the UFC a
little bit because when you were coming
up even me like
social media wasn't a big deal like it I
think it probably started towards the
later end of my career we kind of
started popping like I don't think I had
an Instagram to like my last year in the
UFC it wasn't really a thing like what
20 2012 2011 is when I think I got an
Instagram or something a year before me
I think maybe I got my Twitter like
eight years ago Instagram shortly after
like not that I don't it wasn't a thing
and then now it's like it's everything
man you guys are getting like Main
Events and [ __ ] because they have
millions of followers right it's just a
different game and then also like
they're showing their training and
they're showing all that and like Joe
burrow who's the quarterback for
Cincinnati Bengals Heisman Trophy winner
for uh LSU they said you got any advice
for young kids coming up in college
football and trying to make sure the
pros and he goes don't post your workout
just do it yeah there's like these kids
are too worried about what everyone's
thinking about social media he's like
you know I don't post my work there I
would say stop talking about training
and training yeah stop showing us about
trainers can't stop won't stop it's like
what we got clearly stopped to put this
filter on you know it's weird right but
I mean that's just the nature of the
world the way the world's going right
yeah so and I think what blew the UFC up
is because the UFC is the best at
adapting almost the the marketing
employees made their younger fan base
whatever they're doing but the younger
employees there are always kind of on
the they're on the front end of the
what's pop and what's trending so you'll
see like they sign the note boys yeah
yeah
right three years ago if you're like hey
Dana who are the milk boys like you know
he wants milk you know it's like he
would have no clue you know so it's like
whoever's doing that they know what
they're doing they keep the UFC trending
it's like always it was the second
biggest uh Instagram out of the sport
leagues is it really something NBA's
maybe higher than them or they just
passed them yeah really or is it that
big yeah they're big and they're good at
like the videos and like going viral
like whoever's running that's a genius
yeah no definitely but when you're
fighting it wasn't a thing like no not
at all I mean sometimes [ __ ] to each
other on Twitter but you like not really
but then I think who changed the game
and you're supposed to fight in Conor
McGregor he did like he just changed the
game and I think a lot of Fighters like
oh that's how you get rich and famous
and like get to the top and make all
this money so then it came this like
not authentic kind of watered down
version of the console yeah so I was
like that's not your not your nature and
there's so many fake honors it's crazy
you know he's good at what he I mean the
best ever yeah and he was starting dudes
when he was doing all that too that's
the difference he's like the he's the
green elephant in the circus when all of
us were gray he was a green elephant who
had talked right but the number one
thing that a lot of these kids kids are
forgetting is Connor was starchy dudes
yeah put him out like the Chad Madness
fight the Jose Aldo the fight against
Eddie Alvarez I think it's one of the
best 155ers that I've ever ever anyway
class his fight against Eddie Iverson
155 is insane insane it was but so then
you guys get in there talking [ __ ] it's
like you just went by a decision bro
yeah right right right like Conor did
that and starts Jose out on whatever 13
seconds or whatever it's like you don't
understand he put in the the other side
of it and then this came along with it
well I fight there I I fought that same
weekend Jose Aldo account for I thought
Mendez the night before I'm not going to
knock Mendez out Lorenzo Dana told me
you're getting the title shot [ __ ]
Connor goes out there starts just Aldo I
was like damn There Goes My Title shot
oh that's right
but then you and uh Connor were supposed
to fight yeah remember he was talking
mad trash dude yeah I mean he never
really talked trash to me but actually
believe it or not never over the top
because he goes in on a lot of people
but again I think it's because you know
Connor came up watching you too like
there's a certain there's certain guys
you don't do you don't disrespect Robbie
Lawler yeah yeah dude like there's
certain guys where it's like what are
you doing dude right you know it's like
you just you just don't it's like the
first rule of Fight Club you don't bet
against Frankie unless your communist
you know and Robbie Lawler just like you
don't do that yeah or BJ Penn you don't
yeah right and you also don't you can
talk some [ __ ] if you're supposed to
fight but you don't go too hard yeah you
don't because they're Legends right yeah
so uh he would talk some trash you and
then that fight just never came to
fruition it never happened yeah a couple
times almost happened uh even later on
like I said I wanted to I think I did
interview I'm like yeah I missed on that
you know what my grandkids and say I
fought Conor McGregor yeah I mean listen
whatever you think of him as a fighter
he's still the most polarizing guy you
have in this Sport and he's going to be
of all time he's going to be remembered
that forever I don't think we'll ever
have another yeah
it can be tough I mean maybe
but I mean yeah you could be tough like
he's just a game changer like now how
are you gonna change the game yeah
social media YouTube going that Viral
doing what he did Jose Aldo Eddie
Alvarez Chad Mendez
uh you know
the stuff that he pulled off then the
Floyd Mayweather stuff like that it
seems like those that ship has sailed
like obviously now people are redoing of
the Jake Paul's the world and you know
these crossover fights but the the first
guy to do it yeah I don't know yeah I
mean
I think there'll be someone just like
back in the day when it was the the
stars were Randy Chuck Liddell you know
true and then they're like who's gonna
be next then you have GSP Anderson who's
gonna be next there then you get Connor
someone's gonna be there so you're right
I mean he's definitely the top I'm just
saying as far as like completely like
game like
bigger than the sport like he was the
guy that my mom was like is that Irish
kid fighting like yeah Irish teach them
about Conor McGregor he crossed he
crossed into the mainstream more than
anybody yeah I think it'd be tufty
another one of him again you might be
right listen you're also talking to a
guy who hates electric cars yeah I
refuse to adapt I think I'm with you man
I'm with you I hate him it's so stupid
but um
and how close would the counterfeit ever
anything like I know nothing signed but
not this sign when I when he fought
Mendes no no it wasn't Mendes Mendez on
short notice yeah yeah and we thought
men as a short notice I I that's when I
thought I was going to get get the fight
and they decided to go with man they
decided to go Mendez I think UFC said
yes to me but then he said yes to Mendez
smart at the moment yeah I think so I
think he knew Mendez wasn't training man
there's not trainings in the woods you
know like killing the animals yeah doing
his thing he was like yeah I'll take it
and then remember that that like that
first round wasn't great for coming we
got teamed down too he got Bunch time
that was his game plan too and then
remember he's hit him in like thumbing
up and then hit him with that body like
oh my God
and Mendes he gets tired yeah yeah he's
tired yeah you farming this I did yeah
he messed with him yeah yeah that was
going knocked him out the first round
great one oh yeah that was a big boy
yeah yeah is it weird to see guys that
you know like oh there's a you look at
the list the guys that have retired like
just in the past year it's like I mean
it's a Hall of Famer list oh yeah Aldo
uh Cowboy you know yeah Cowboy you wanna
that's right yeah yeah like just and I'd
say Dela Sean now yeah dillshaw just
retired yeah yeah you look at the list
you're like holy [ __ ] I mean it's bound
to happen getting older yeah yeah it's
like we're just getting older man for
real it's [ __ ] scary because it's
like I remember the first like you want
us first fight johanna's first fight and
like when Chad man is retiring like TJ
I'm like I remember when he was just
like it's coming up yeah I feel like
those guys are young and compared to
them all those guys I know except Cowboy
Captain Cowboy same but everyone else
came in after me Cowboys been doing a
hot second yeah Cowboy is a guy who you
know obviously retire but you know on to
bigger better things another guy like a
lot of Fighters can kind of look at him
because you know he's just you know he's
saying where there's like so much
respect there that the same that you
have with your fan base and the hard
Chords it's like Cowboys like this he
even though he's not he doesn't really
need to fight I think he's the same with
you it's like the respects there and
like people are intrigued with what you
guys doing with Cowboys like this bigger
than life personality he did his way too
he did you know yeah so he was like
[ __ ] what is it uh Wade Borden or
wake wake board and a date week in a
fight
and [ __ ] like yeah like running bulls
and [ __ ] like the day of the fight
you're just like this dude is wild he's
Wild Man definitely wild boy yeah he's
uh mean Cowboy go way back when I didn't
have money he let me stay in his house
to train at Jackson Jacksonville Jim
he's on the fight companion on a Friday
I haven't seen him in a hot second he's
a fun dude too yeah you know I'm curious
to ask him it's like and you weren't
this guy like I always respected your
career like you're pretty
business-minded about I don't know if
it's your manager you picking the fights
prefer Cowboy it's like
that anytime anywhere mentality which
the fans love at the end of the day
we've never seen a guy who's been
anytime anywhere get the title you know
it's a tough business because you're
taking short notice fights you're not
prepared and this guy's prepared so
sometimes it works for you you might be
compensated a little extra when you do
that but in the I think in the grand
scheme of things which the goal is to be
the champ the champ it'd be hard to be
that guy right agreed yeah it was just
like Tyler was the perfect guy for that
you know now guys like like Patty Pam
it's hilarious speaking of change of the
guard Patty Penman I was like you know
he was damn near 220 pounds he's so
thick dude I've seen multiple Burgers
like just a great dude and I go hey uh
and this is hey what if they ask you to
take a short notice fight at 55 dude you
drop you know 70 pounds or whatever and
he started laughing like straight up
laughing like I told some great joke and
he's like no why would I take a short
notice fight he's like I would never
it's smart because I make more money
outside of fighting I do fightings I
would never kill myself and take a short
nose fight like even these guys that are
like uh who was it uh
I can't think of who it was Blake
they're like I'm not taking a fight
until I'm getting paid money you know
it's smart like me when I was coming up
I'm like I'll fight let me give you the
best guy give me the best guy I'll fight
anybody because I thought that was the
mentality to get to the top it was a
mentality but then also especially when
we were coming up too you were before me
but I was you know right in the middle
the height like when you were when you
won your belt when I was in the UFC so
it's like I was there when you're doing
the damn thing but we didn't have a lot
of Leverage either like guys now like
you look at sugar shadow now you got
Patty pimlet a lot of them yeah yeah
sugar yeah SMART Bus smart they just
they got a beer contract all right now
fight Peter Ian yeah and for him it's
like hold up dude I make this much off
twitch I make this much off Facebook
YouTube my Instagram and I'm undefeated
it's like nah that's not even worth it
to me so he's like damn and they
literally he's like all right you making
this much so we gotta switch it up yeah
so there's just more leverage there's
more ways for guys to make money now
than before yeah no definitely it's just
a different game it is different and you
it's going to keep evolving as it goes
right you think I think so yeah yeah I
think so you can get I think what's
happening now like your son's into you
know obviously wrestling yeah football
and UFC in general my son's into it so
it's like you're gonna get kids who yeah
they're gonna wrestle because you know
that's one aspect of mixed martial arts
but you're asking kids who they wrestle
they're doing Jitsu on side but they're
they they're doing some martial arts and
boxing because they're they have the
hopes to get to the UFC so yeah you're
just going to get a better athlete over
time yeah yeah because we're still
seeing it out you're seeing it now oh
dude somebody's gone nuts nuts you'll
know that the game changer at
heavyweight that heavy because you know
in America like our heavyweight athletes
are NFL it's like no giant dude you know
out of Georgia if you're like hey what
do you want to do he's like I'm going to
fight in the UFC he's like I'm playing
football in Georgia I'm being drafted by
the Tennessee Titans like that's the
game plan right you know so I think
eventually especially once the pay
starts picking up people will start
you're gonna get those big boys yeah the
real like are real real athletes yeah
yeah that that I mean imagine LeBron
James fighting you know someone that
size yeah
pretty crazy he'd have to get tougher
but yeah yeah yeah I'm saying his body
now I feel you like that freak of an
athlete yeah you're nuts too heavy wild
I mean nuts yeah that's what's going to
happen with your son it's tough like I
struggle with it too I tell my son I'm
like no no one who's fought in the UFC
their dads don't drive Ferraris but you
know what I'm saying it's like like when
I uh did food truck with Tyson I was
like you know they say uh boxing comes
from the streets and dude he just
stopped eating was like it comes from
the gutters I was like yeah no doubt
yeah you know it's like it's tough to
come from a you know a good life and
want to fight because you know you know
it's better than anybody even in 17
years it's like and you've been at the
highest level it's like it's the hardest
gig in the world man it's like it's not
yeah you got to want to do this it's not
like you don't do this to pay bills you
got to want to do this yeah bills you
know it's not going to last long agree
yeah it has to be more than the money
yeah you know like obviously you want to
be compensated but right it you kind of
got it that hopefully it comes but you
got you got to be more set on being
Champion than anything yeah exactly what
the championship comes the money you
know yeah exactly like you know people
go they ask me like oh do you think
Connor's gonna fight again I was like
yeah I think he does but I don't think
we'll ever get the the hungry Connor who
what he did to Jose Aldo what he did to
Eddie Alvarez I don't or even with
khabib even though you know he's a wild
boy during that camp but just that
tenacity and like that drive I don't
know if you can compete at that level
when you have a yacht Gucci sheets yeah
it's it's like because he's on this
yacht he's gonna have to you know uh
Dr yacht find a camp you know
the Four Seasons eating good it's like
and you're fighting makajav it was he
wrote here on a go you know you don't
know what Gucci is and he's making money
he doesn't give up yeah that's like
khabib yeah khabib's like uh you know
the Queen of England we have no idea how
much money is you're right you're right
they say he is he's stupid Rich yeah and
drives like a Toyota like Tundra around
Dagestan yeah they don't care he don't
give it like he's not doing for money
like he just I think he still live with
like his mom and dad before his dad
passed he's just chilling yeah I've read
that his mom still lives
you know it's like and you're fighting
naptime and you're on a yacht and Gucci
sheets it starts to compete there it's
just there's nothing like fighting
that's why I respect like uh you know
guys like Floyd Mayweather even yourself
like you're doing so long man I'm sure
financially you're good but it's like
especially Floyd not now now he's
fighting like YouTubers and that it's
like how much money do you need but like
before when he was like 40 you know 45
and up you're like and then he's
fighting like tough guys even even when
he was you know 35 40 no and he yeah
[ __ ] now he's younger when canelo's
younger but it's like at that level
you're still able to like dominate and
win not get hit and you're talking about
a guy you know supposedly worth a two
billion dollars like to me that's insane
yeah really guy like Tom Brady right
yeah well it's like I mean what are we
doing yeah I mean you know Love of the
Game yeah love the game you know for you
that you played football in the
beginning you [ __ ] loved it yeah I
mean yeah yeah yeah and for you it was
always always fighting from day one like
wrestling you always want to be a
fighter I mean I didn't I got well you
know come to wrestling I didn't know UFC
wasn't really a thing yeah you know so I
didn't I was a [ __ ] plumber really
you know I mean yeah and then once
fighting came around I didn't want to
Plumbing to Plumbing no more so I was
like yeah that plumber has great
footwork
I could honestly I didn't know [ __ ] I
could dig a hole like a [ __ ]
that's about it that's a tough gig dude
yeah my my old man owned the apartment
company so that commercial commercial
plumber no there's no people's toilets
and stuff oh gotcha when I was carrying
pipe digging holes and stuff you know
yeah like blue color like yeah so so for
you it was like what was it was like
you're wrestling and then you kind of
fell into UFC well I mean I I graduated
college
I was a political science major because
I don't know how that happened I went to
school to wrestle yeah and I just
happened I graduated I thought I thought
I might be a cop so I did policy that's
cool so uh
I remember trying out for the cop thing
I passed the test and I did the
interview and I they're like you know
just the you know cops were trying to
grill you and stuff in my mind you know
I'm playing a game put in my head I'm
like there's no way I'm gonna be a cop I
walked that interview I got the job and
I was like I'm not taking this oh really
yeah just because they kind of turned
out yeah I just turned you off you know
like if someone's someone's saying stuff
what are you gonna do then I'm like I'm
gonna do nothing yes he's all no you oh
you told me the Jersey cops weren't
friendly yeah right like these guys are
nice so then you weren't gonna do the
cops yeah so then I worked you know I
got into Union I started working as a
plumber I did that for a couple years uh
I was fighting right away I fought like
three weeks after I came home from
school because you because you got done
with wrestling and who was like hey you
should try take Friday well no it was
The Ultimate Fighter season one came out
my senior year in college so I remember
watching it and uh
and he wrestled for Edinburgh Russ
McLaren we've wrestled each other all
the time oh [ __ ] I know him you know and
I'm like oh [ __ ] wrestlers could do this
yeah I'm like well I'm gonna definitely
find a place to train Kurt Pellegrino no
I remember Kurt uh was it Batman Batman
yeah yeah what a throwback hit the
Batman
he's badass they're Jiu-Jitsu girl good
wrestler I know him from wrestling he's
still alive yeah he is yeah yeah he's a
badass all right still he runs to school
his guy Frank Francis Marshall just
fought oh yeah yeah that's his guy oh
damn yeah what a throwback name and I
hit him I'm like hey I'm uh you know I
want to train he's like yeah he said
well I'm actually moving to Florida next
week he's like we'll come to my gym and
you can train here for this week so I
was like all right and a guy took over
that gym so I just stayed and who took
over that gym this guy Rob garino who's
low-level you know coach whatever so you
just started going in there started
going there and I fought three weeks
later just in a regional show you know
underground show New York [ __ ] I'm
talking about yeah underground that's
right it was in sanctioned here yeah I
hadn't it was no rules no weigh-in I was
the main I ended up being a main event
uh we were doing one 15 minute round
straight old there's some Lionheart band
damn [ __ ] yeah dudes were in the it was
in Bronx in the Bronx in a boxing gym
like 200 degrees in the middle of July
and people drinking 40s in the stands
this sounds fantastic my my dad was on
the road so I'm fighting what yeah yeah
but uh the guy you fought with same size
or yeah I used piece pretty much same
size yeah uh yeah I had bought him in a
fight wow that was my go-to in the
street fights yeah yeah oh yeah holy
[ __ ] so you had about this through and
that's is that how you won well I had
bought him in that you know that
mountain of decal and then from there
you're like man let's keep rolling I did
I broke my face and I fight too though
from the headbutt no he actually called
me in the Thai Thai clinician and he
didn't need me of writing like the first
like 30 seconds
so you know I didn't
didn't notice or you know hurt felt hurt
a little bit and we went out to dinner
after into went to North to the
Portuguese restaurants in North okay
afterwards I want my family I go in the
bathroom my nose was bleeding a little
bit I didn't look like I even fought
yeah I blow my nose my whole face filled
up whatever I was like what the [ __ ]
yeah we're sitting there hey my coach
sitting trying to push to push the air
out of my eye it's science I go outside
my mom's like Oh my god what happened we
went to the hospital again you broke
your sinus passes Jesus and so you're
out for how long was that I mean a
couple weeks you know yeah there's no
commission give me a 60-day system I was
on a job site on Monday though just a
plumber just eyes like a goldfish one of
those fat goldfish and so then you could
take that fight and then you have five
before you get in the UFC then I had
five yeah Five Points five in the UFC
and more underground fights no that was
only there's only one yeah probably best
yeah and then uh so then you start doing
like the Regional Surgery I did the
regional the uh um ring of combat
reality fight and ring combat a lot of
guys can mess around yeah hell yeah
Chris Weidman yeah dude yeah uh you're
right you're right hog came out of there
yeah yeah right yeah yeah some real
baddest came out there and then you try
out for the The Ultimate Fighter season
five season five yeah five yes the first
season for 155. and then they go then
UFC goes we're all set we don't we don't
want Frankie but then they call you and
if I if memory serves right you fight
Tyson Griffin Griffin yeah Tyson Griffin
I'm gonna go and say this on record best
legs of all time in the UFC thick bronze
legs and this ass is glutes and it's
quads yeah any of that you know that
head it was like this he's a giant head
just a sap into your hand yeah yeah yeah
and that's your first fight in UFC
if I again if I remember I have Splash
CT be cool he'd get you in a knee bar he
did get your knee bar right I mean kind
of not really it it popped twice it
popped twice
um but I knew there was like a minute
left I'm like [ __ ] it you know get a
little later and uh I got it I gotta
pass like the the full crew yeah yeah so
then I was like all right I'm good like
this sucks I give him trying to give
dead legs you know for the last 30
seconds and then you won be a decision
first fight this is kids taking up your
first fight in the UFC this is how the
game changer first one you see against
Tyson Griffin yeah who is a monster and
I remember I took that fight on four
weeks notice and I had I had a sinus
infection for two weeks I was like the
worst science facts of my life it barely
trained yeah I could barely trained and
uh do you think it's from the head putt
back in the day or no no no no no no
honestly wondering what it's from I I
got punched in my tooth training for the
fight I got an abscess in my tooth so I
had to get a root canal the infection
root canal leads to science infections
can I guess and that's what happened
and I was I was struggling man and uh I
remember got so tired in that fight that
I thought I had a concussion because I
was throwing up on the way back to that
exhausted Robotics and stuff probably
pressure yeah yeah yeah and I remember
going back I'm in the locker room laying
down like hey Lorenzo I didn't know [ __ ]
I've like really got into fighting I
didn't know much about it right Lorenzo
was talking I'm like well tell him he's
got to wait they're like nah get the
[ __ ] up and talk to this guy
this is the guy there's Dana then
there's he's the final boss yeah right
right so he came in he was like wow
great fight I'm like oh thank you man he
was cool yeah cool [ __ ] yeah the
fertitas were always great they were
[ __ ] if I had any issues I'd go
around the big boys I feel like uh that
that family feel of UFC left with them I
agree yeah it's more it's more business
now it's more corporate now right with
them it's more there's more heart and
soul yeah and yeah not not that's a bad
thing it's the progression yeah it's
just Mickey Mouse like I'll take it from
him right right yeah okay it seems
strange but yeah that's what happened so
yeah so then you see and then yeah Tyson
Griffin you go on this crazy freaking
streak man it's just nuts because now
like your son wants to come up in the
game
there's not an exact blueprint but
there's more of a blueprint than we were
finally yeah I fell into it too there
was it wasn't a plan you just kind of
fell into it yeah like but now kids can
kind of
go I won't fight in UFC it's like we can
you can you know do this train this
train this and then you know get in the
regional scene become the champion there
and then hopefully he knows you and now
you have the Dana White Contender series
which I think is the best route to the
UFC so that's the ultimate fighter okay
I mean listen if you're a guy that's
great but if you're you have to win
emphatically on the contender series to
get signed yeah it has to be an exciting
fight and you got to win and oh and
everyone like these guys are good
they're really these guys coming off
contenders yo those guys that went by
decision and then well that like that
guy just uh his name is Brendan shout
out to Brendan he uh one on Dana White
Contender series pretty exciting fight
everyone's like oh he's I bet he gets a
contract and Daniel's like nah we're
good we're gonna go that other guy threw
a spinning heel kick who's you know not
doing much now in the UFC all right that
guy's like okay cool I'm gonna take my
ball and go to pfl he just won the pfl
won a million bucks oh yeah I just said
a Brennan low hand yeah something like
that yeah great stories yeah he's shot
that's right he took a shot in the last
maybe it has a blessing in disguise
right there but when you look at that
Contender series like you look at the
names that come out of there like Jamal
Hill uh sugar Shawn O'Malley and then I
think the the Next Great White Hope
since you're retiring uh bo nickel oh
yeah man yeah Bo nickel's a stoplight
dude he is even if he's one of those
weird crypto stocks I know it's dice
right now I would invest and I don't
need Jim krause's information like I'm
in dude like Bo nickel is what are you
supposed to fight though and somehow
right I was supposed to fight oh bonus
I'm not supposed to fight nipples I
don't want them problems uh yeah he got
injured and then they pushed him he's
supposed to I don't can't be too bad
because I heard you supposed to fight in
December I think he's they pushed to the
beginning of the year but he's a guy
like
it always takes a lot for me to like
really put stocking especially I don't
have a lot of fights and you look at the
like just his foundation already with
that elite wrestling background and then
the way he's been trained ATT and like
guys like Mazda doll like everybody I
know like the the gym stores they hear
about him like you should see his Jiu
Jitsu dude yeah I'm just like he's only
like technically he's only a blue belt
but you saw that either like inverted
triangle like his like his transition
where he won that fight when he came on
here he was on food truck I'm like who
the [ __ ] is only giving you a blue belt
dude yeah you need to talk to your coach
does that transition dude that ain't
blue belt I don't know what Jim you're
training that dude I mean he's a he's
one of the best wrestlers ever come out
of division one you know he's going to
be a freak Savage he's funny because I
was like man there's like this surge of
Russian pakistanians I come and I was
like aren't you like you know you you've
called out homside like you want to
fight him when you first find UFC which
is like man it's so crazy but right
that's the guy that's the type of that's
the mentality you need though right I
mean you follow Tyson Graphics yeah yeah
so you're like that's crazy nickels holy
[ __ ] Frank said that's crazy but do you
find Tyson Griffin which is nuts and
you've got a sinus infection right so
for him it's like we called out homside
when you think about like
yeah like you okay yeah I mean like I
don't love it from at first because and
I I was um we had Laura sank on who's
you know the kind of the face of uh
January and I was talking about Bo Nick
I go if I'm Beau Nichols manager if if
I'm the UFC like I'll see the bow nickel
train is coming so he had I think one or
two he had one fight on Fight Pass it's
the most watched thing that you're on
Fight Pass wow there's a demand fund wow
yeah so they put them on Contender
series after that right and he's starch
into it yeah starching dudes and my
whole thing with that is like is he a
top 15 guy middleweight in the world
absolutely but you need all this better
than anyone you know you won't talk
about a marathon your 15-year Marathon
for me with Beau it's like hey man it's
a marathon on Sprint so yeah can you
beat homdot maybe you'll be a slight
Underdog you probably shouldn't win that
fight but damn I'd probably bet on you
dude you could I could see you pulling
that off but then what then you don't
have the experience you're gonna be
fighting the izzies of the world you
know you're fighting these monsters and
just take it slow and earn your money
and get paid you know so it's like so I
was like well just keep finding
condensers to give experience until they
launch you right you know into the Big
Boy show and just be the champion like
if I'm Dana White condensers I make bone
nickel the face of it making the
champion he's this dominant Champion it
would suck for the guys who have to
fight him because Claire's not going to
get a chance but just make him the face
of it and Laura senko she was great
about it she goes run
go through 15 to 6 who's going to beat
him I know I was like you got a good
point
she's like so if you want he wants to go
you know he wants to yeah yeah yeah he's
he's a winner he's a winner he's a
winner yeah he's the only guy too where
we never booked somebody on food truck
if so if they fight on Saturday we never
book them for the following week just
because you never know what's gonna
happen like Anthony Smith God bless one
of my favorites he's one of the best
analysts too amazing fighter we booked
him before he fought uh magaman who
fights you know yeah and you know his
like ankle broke so he's like dude I
apologize he was great about it you have
to have surgery I'm going to make him
push it I'm like don't worry about it
right so told the team no more booking
Fighters yes who are fighting that
weekend because even if they win it
might be a problem
then they go hey uh Bo Nichols team
reached out they want to have him on
okay he's one of my favorites so you
know he fights Saturday going cool book
it yeah yeah what do you mean like
bookkeep I would I guarantee you he wins
yeah he's the one guy we can book he's
the one guy we can book you know like
I'm not booking you you know back in the
day when you're fighting you know great
Mania yeah yeah you know Frankie wins
it's gonna be it's gonna be a world up
here yeah a little banged up but yeah
the game just changed man I think a lot
of these Fighters have you to think for
it you know your legend of the game man
I know that has to be weird getting
compliments I did I'm I'm like uh yeah
I'm not good with that yeah because
you're not a narcissist yeah yeah if you
were like yeah keep going yeah tell me
Tell Donald Trump and me yeah yeah yeah
yeah keep going
um you won gold jacket no but
um yeah I think the guys have a lot to
kind of pave the way for a lot of guys
and it must feel pretty good to look
back on the career I'm sure your
family's proud of you you're the first
guest ever on food truck Diaries man
here we are now and I've won John for
quite some time now for every fighter my
boys at suplex in Philly I'm a sneaker
head so it's my gift to you for doing a
show it's not just about the cold
barbecue sandwiches that you had no
choice in so anyway uh we just don't
give you cold food I always give uh the
guests some sneakers from suplex in
Philly Philly's not too far from
yourself so take care if you go in store
too but
um of course these are your size but I
can't give a walking Legend anything but
some Jordans awesome J's they're like
what about some Yeezys I went oh yeah
why don't we hey suplex why don't we
chill out on the Yeezys for a while
right until Frankie how dare you so I
was like dude you gotta have some not
only do I need some Jordans but I need
some of the classic ones to go which
ones are your favorites I said the one
fours and fives so here's some fours for
you my man wow and this says Mr Edgar
huge longtime fans here at suplex please
wear enjoy these Jordan fours uh we're
not far from Jersey either right on the
South Street in Philly stopping whenever
we got you thanks for everything so
these are for you my man
yeah super dope some legendary sneakers
for a legend sweet man thank you bro
what do you got now some Steve Madden's
no I got some Aldos bro okay well we're
getting older we're getting older dog
cheap we got those fly kicks now yeah
some Legend kicks for a legend brother
you're the best hey man this is a great
time thank you egg everybody if you're
into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding